it's great to welcome back to the
program today johav dror who is the ceo
and co-founder of pumapay pumapay.io
for more information uh yoav it's great
to have you on today
hi david nice being back here so i mean
let's just first remind the audience
uh tell us a little bit about the
pumapay project
and about your background uh what what
was the idea here
yeah so uh i'm coming from a background
of a
high-risk high transaction uh business
online businesses
and back in the old days in 2017
when the first crypto revolution was
just coming about we started to think
how we can utilize this technology
in our business and after
lots of thinking we came up with a the
conclusion
that what is a massively broken in
any high-risk business is payments so
we decided to fund
a puma pay which is all about crypto
payments
but with a little a twist
uh before puma pay the only type of
transaction you could do is just
a simple push you could send a
crypto to someone else to another party
with poompe
you can deploy advanced billing model
logic onto the blockchain which in
simple words
meaning that you can do subscriptions
and top-ups and
and other billing logics that are very
common in a
high risk especially in iris industries
and
were not available in the blockchain
before so in a nutshell
pumapay is about advanceability models
about subscriptions about top-ups
etc yeah one of the early you know we
for processing subscriptions on our
website we have two integrations we have
a paypal integra
integration and we have a stripe
integration and two of the great things
about that
is we can set up those subscriptions we
can set up
monthly or every number of days or
yearly
and we're essentially pulling those
payments which of course are
pre-authorized and that's a big part of
this being able to have that entire
recurring payment ecosystem people would
come to me and say
you should accept crypto for
subscriptions and i
would say i'm glad to accept it but the
right now someone has to every month
remember to send me a payment there's no
subscription integration
that's what you're tackling for
high-risk industries
correct and not only for high-risk
industries we're tackling it for
any industry we're tackling uh
subscriptions
recurring transactions for crypto in
general
and we have several layers to our
solution first of all
there's the protocol layer where we
enable
all these authorizations and pooling and
reverse
a transaction mechanism via
an architecture of smart contracts that
facilitates this
but on top of that we also added a layer
of products to manage your subscription
as
a as a merchant you want to manage your
subscriptions you want to create
building model widgets to put on your
website so you can collect subscriptions
you want to see your subscribers you
want to be able to
change subscriptions to response to the
request and as a user
you want to be in control of your
subscription you want to be able
to cancel subscription to ask for a
refund etc so we built
a whole layer of products on top of the
protocol to facilitate
this okay so i i want to talk about
some of the key changes for puma pay
version 3.
i think maybe to get into that it would
be good to explain
across crypto over the last several
years
there have been real issues with
transaction fees and
it's not just sometimes the speed with
which
transactions are taking place which on
some networks has slowed down
a lot uh but also the cost of a lot of
these transactions so talk to us a
little bit about that
and then what led you to develop version
three now
yeah so we implemented our first
version of subscriptions i think it was
october or november 2018.
thereafter we continued we added we
built some more products
and we introduced a more a
robust and final a
product toward the end
around let's say september or october
2019
shortly after a we saw the gas prices
started increasing okay our
our implementation is so far on the
ethereum network
and you know ethereum was the gold
standard for a decentralized application
development
and slowly slowly we started seeing the
problems and we we started
getting the feedback from merchants who
integrated with us
and they said hey the the gas prices are
increasing and
it reached a a state where
merchants were had to pay
more than ten dollars to charge a
customer
less than ten dollars so it didn't make
any sense at all
right so and and we just see you know
it's just uh the problem just
uh uh escalates every every week every
month it becomes a a
bigger problem so we went back to the
drawing board and we
tried to find a solution for this
and we evaluated many solutions many
different solutions and
eventually we decided to migrate our
protocol from ethereum
to binance marching and on binance
marching according to
our preliminary calculations we can see
transactions that are a hundred times
faster and 50 times cheaper than what we
currently have
so instead of paying dollars for the gas
phase it's not even something that puma
pay earns
it's just for the blockchain for the
processing the transaction so instead of
paying dollars
merchants will have to pay just cents
that's
uh um i mean that it seems like that
alone could be the difference maker in
terms of adoption right because this is
such a barrier
for many people when they look and they
say okay even if i want to make a
hundred dollar payment and it costs ten
dollars it's just too much
yeah i totally agree but this is not the
only improvement that we're doing i mean
i totally agree that
this was a huge barrier for adoption
another barrier that we discovered uh
at the beginning our approach we said
that we will try to convert
credit card paying users to to become
crypto paying
users and on our first implementation
everyone had to have
a balance in pma tokens so they can
subscribe
and pay the subscription and if you
didn't have the pma token you couldn't
subscribe
and that didn't work too well
and so we decided part of this migration
we decided
uh to support more tokens okay
so on a finance smart chain you know
they support multiple tokens including a
wrapped bitcoin or binance pack bitcoin
and they
wrap the ether up b and whatever so we
can allow
customers to choose uh
subscribing to a subscription building
models or top-up building models with
the
tokens they already have in their wallet
you don't even have to know about the
pma token
on the other hand we allow merchants to
have
their uh payments settled in whatever
currency they choose
it can be bitcoin it can be b it can
also be usd
if they want to avoid a
crypto volatility risk okay so we can
have
a user paying a b in bnb another user
paying in bitcoin and the merchant
eventually being settled with
usd and this is being done with the help
of
a further decentralization of the
protocol and introduction of liquidity
pools
such that any transaction that is not a
pma transaction which
let's say be honest most of the
transaction will not be pma transaction
but so any transaction and bnb
transaction will be first converted to
pma
thereafter the pma will be converted to
the merchant's
settlement currency okay such that there
are two conversions here all in
one transaction so there are no extra
gas cost and the pma token
acts as a mediator in that way the
merchant
and the user are agnostic to each other
choice of coin
and they don't even have to care or know
about the pma token
it acts behind the scenes for them now
the v3 development what happens
to people with pma tokens
under the ethereum paradigm now as you
switch
to the binance platform
absolutely nothing they can keep their
token
we created a bridge between
ethereum and binance marching bridge for
the pma token
anyone who wishes can uh
transfer the tokens from ethereum to
binance smart chain
they can transfer it back if they wish
but they can keep it on ethereum nothing
will change we keep our token listed on
the exchanges where we are currently
listed which is
mainly a bittrex okay x uh hitbtc
and several others uh so there is no
need to transfer any tokens anyone can
transfer the tokens through the bridge
but they don't have to they can keep it
there
on the ethereum network and and we we
will continue you know to
support this token as well got it um you
have you know one of the things that's
very common with a lot of blockchain
projects is that
the word decentralized is used
but oftentimes there is not actually
decentralization at least in many
aspects of the project or of how a
certain blockchain works
talk to us a little bit about that i
mean the the pl if i understand
correctly the plan for puma pay
is real decentralization correct
correct you know i'm old enough to
remember
that uh 21 years ago in the
in the dot-com bubble every company
would add
dot-com to their name and their stock
would go berserk so
maybe it has the same effect you know
adding the word decentralized or
decentralization
but in essence a
you know decentralization or
decentralized platform is a platform
that is not governed by any
a single entity and this is what we plan
for the pumapay protocol in the long run
so we have decided as part of this week
we will also introduce another
um participant in our ecosystem
we call it the executor nodes
and in a nutshell it will be
a decentralized version of our existing
back end
so we take our back end the the modules
that are responsible
you know to record the transaction and
remember who do we need to charge and
when
right transferring tokens from this user
to that merchant on this date and that
day
so we just decentralize all this as as a
module as an sdk
that anyone can run on their computer
like they run you know
a mining modules and a
this decentralized network of executor
nodes will be responsible
to post the transactions on behalf of
the merchants and the users
and they will be able also to charge a
small fee
from the merchants for processing their
transactions
saying this any merchant will be able
to be an executor as well and process
their own transactions such that not
only
they won't have any processing fees but
they will also be able to make money by
processing
other merchants uh transactions
merchants that
doesn't want to run a node understood
um last thing what's up ahead on the
roadmap we
you talked a little bit about v3 what
other pumapay projects are on the
horizon now
so v3 is the main thing as part of
v3 there are many things that we're
planning we spoke about
the liquidity pools we spoke about about
the bridge which is already live
we spoke about the executor nodes we're
also
uh we intend to uh
improve the onboarding process for
merchants to our business console we
intend to
ease it up as much as a
regulation permits okay if it's up to me
i wouldn't ask any
kyc from anyone but you know regulation
is a regulation so we'll have to comply
but i want to ease it up both for
merchants and for users
we intend to introduce a web wallet
up until now users have to download our
mobile wallet app which is part of the
system
but at v3 they will be able to use a
meta mask or a a binance wallet or trust
wallet
to do their transactions they'll be able
to connect to a web wallet and manage
all their subscriptions from there
in addition to that we are something
that we spoke about in the past
but we never had a chance to execute but
we
plan to do it after we introduce these
three is uh
introducing plugins for uh you know a
for popular ecommerce uh platforms like
shopify like a wordpress etc
and and in essence our aim is to make
a poompa more accessible both for
merchants and for users
and cheaper and easier and faster and
better
all right we've been speaking with johav
dror who's the ceo
and co-founder of pumapay you can learn
more at pumapay.io
you have always great speaking to you
thank you
same